[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm Jessica.
And I'm going to be talking
about a chemical demonstration
today that I like to call
bringin' home the bacon.
Now, before we get
cooking let's take a look
at the chemist's best friend.
This is the periodic table.
It was created in 1869 by
the Russian chemist Dmitri
Mendeleev back when only
65 elements were known.
Different elements
on the periodic table
require different numbers
of electrons to be happy.
Electrons live in the
shells surrounding atoms.
And when an atom's outermost
shell is filled to capacity,
the atom is happy.
Now hydrogen, over here, has
one electron in its outer shell
and needs just one
more to fill it.
Carbon has four electrons
in its outer shell
and needs four more, a total
of eight electrons, to fill it.
Now on the left and middle of
the table, we have the metals.
To get to eight electrons
in their outer shell,
the metals lose electrons.
And on the right side of the
table, we have nonmetals.
To get to eight electrons,
these elements gain electrons.
And hydrogen is
the only nonmetal
that's on the left hand
side of the periodic table.
Now one way atoms get eight
electrons in their outer shell
is through chemical bonds.
A bond is the sharing of two
electrons between two atoms.
So carbon likes to
have four bonds.
And hydrogen likes to have one.
Knowing about where
the electrons are
and how they
participate in bonding
is central to many important
things in the real world.
For example, unsaturated
fats have a double bond,
lots of electrons.
And that gives them
special reactivity,
which can lead to
the spoiling of food
when the bonds
react with oxygen.
So we like to know if there
are double bonds in our food
molecules.
But how is that determined?
So this is what a happy carbon
hydrogen molecule looks like.
But in some cases, there are
not enough hydrogen atoms.
And the carbon will
have to double bond
with another carbon
to share electrons.
This molecule is more
reactive than this one
because a carbon-carbon
double bond is not
as stable as a
carbon-carbon single bond.
Now let's watch as
MIT's Dr. John Dolhun
uses bromine to test for
the presence of double bonds
in a big ol' slab of bacon.
Here he is at the
Cambridge Science Festival.
[WHOOSH]
JOHN DOLHUN: I'm going to
trun on my burner here.
OK, there we go.
So I'm going to take
my bacon, the fat.
Basically shake it up a bit.
You can see the red color of
the bromine is going away.
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP: So Dr. Dolhun
heats up a piece of bacon
and adds it to a flask
filled with bromine.
Bromine reacts with
anything that has
a carbon-carbon double bond.
This includes the
acrolein that's
produced when you cook
bacon, which looks like this,
as well as the
unsaturated fat that's
already present in the bacon.
Unsaturated fats
are fats that have
carbon-carbon double bonds.
Fully saturated fats have no
They're all carbon-carbon
single bonds.
And they're the ones
that are bad for you.
The breaking of the double
bond looks like this.
We can tell that the reaction
happens because the red color
disappears.
That's the bromine reacting
with those carbon-carbon double
bonds.
In our video recording
of the experiment,
it's hard to see
the color change.
So watch again very closely.
[WHOOSH]
Hope you enjoyed the video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'll see you next time.